there's like a photo snow let's go get
it Pro skier Kyle smain has died he was
31 years old
smain was in Japan when his party was
hit by an avalanche Japan
and it's
insane he was documenting the trip on
social media in Japan we may as well see
the path
it's Maine's final post he said this is
what brings me back to Japan each winter
non-stop storms and really fun Terrain
yeah
a photographer on the trip recounts the
Fatal incident on Instagram
tried to run but was thrown 50 meters by
the air blast and buried winter for me
has always been a season of Discovery
and exploration both of the outdoors but
also discovering myself
this means wife of a little more than
two months telling him in a tribute you
loved skiing more than anyone I've ever
met and could never blame you for doing
what you loved she reveals that many
people didn't know they married in
November after 13 years together quote
I'm so incredibly thankful that I got to
have you in my life this is Kyle Spain
former world champion Half-Life skier
High Point in Spain's career winning
gold at one of the ski world's biggest
competitions in 2015.
[Applause]
[Music]